hi there Steve here today I want to talk
about listening I want to talk about
listening and content people know people
often say to me well you always say we
should listen but how can we listen to
stuff that we don't understand of course
you shouldn't listen to stuff that you
don't understand now it may be that to
some degree having language content
blaring in the background you pick up a
word here a word there I mean it's not
bad for you but it's not very effective
in terms of language learning ultimately
you have to listen to things that you
can understand or that you can have a
chance of understanding where you
understand 50 60 70 percent so how do
you get there well obviously you start
with easy material short material
material where you have the transcript
or you can look up the words where you
can listen over and over again where
it's easy and stuff but ultimately to
become fluent you need to listen to more
substantial interesting compelling
content so I think it's very important
that in our language learning strategy
we start thinking about how to find that
compelling content I believe that what
you use as your starter material whether
it be teach yourself as see mill
duolingo
duolingo beginner material at link it
read almost doesn't matter that's that
as I described in my previous video
that's that steep part of the upside
down hockey stick you got to get through
it it's not gonna be very compelling
interesting but you're motivated because
you want to get a grip on that language
but once you get to the the longer shaft
in the in the learning process you have
to find interesting content and there's
a lot of it out there
there when I compare say to 50 years ago
I mean there's audible.com there's not a
Toyota for Italian content there's audio
teka which I found which has a number of
languages how do you like audio Tek a so
you can find lots of audio material then
you have to look for the transcript to
go with that and here again personally I
like 19th century author
whether it be post or whether it be he
promised palsy in Italian or Balzac I
love that stuff and it has the advantage
that you can find the transcript free of
charge you can find the e-book free of
charge on Gutenberg org you can import
that in the link if you're on link so
you can learn the words and phrases as
you're listening to the audio I very
much think it's worthwhile paying for
high quality audio
in other words good sound quality good
storytellers because we create this this
emotional connection I made a tweet
today about the fact that I can still
hear even meritorious rendition of a
promise he's Posey and I remember where
I was 10 years ago listening to this so
to me 19th century literature is is
readily available however I think it's a
very good investment if you are not
interested in that and you're interested
in some other subject buy the e-book by
the audiobook it's a great investment
you know $20 it's gonna keep you busy
for potentially months as you work your
way through this material or you know
and how do you find this stuff well if
you don't know how to say for example
audiobook ebook in whatever language
French German Chinese use Google
Translate to get that wording that you
need Google for it and you will find
lots of content podcasts look up podcast
get in the habit of searching for you
know compelling content if it's free
good and fine and dandy if you have to
pay for it it's a good investment so you
know to repeat that I think listening is
key listening has this tremendous
advantage that you can do it wherever
you want
get yourself you know an mp3 player or
use your iPhone it's it's very portable
it's something you can do while doing
other tasks but of course you have to
eventually get the compelling content
to my mind you know what my beginner
material you use almost doesn't matter
and you may also want to move to the
sort of intermediate level material
which is these graded readers and there
again you can search for graded readers
in Spanish I know Ollie Richards in the
UK puts out a good series of graded
readers in these different languages so
you gotta have a strategy that takes you
from the the starter book and that's
almost like it's a given it's that
ladder that gets you up to the next
level but there once you're past that
you have to have a strategy to find that
compelling content content that's
interesting that's accessible to you
that consists of audio and transcript so
that you can then mine the text for
words and phrases so I just wanted to
comment a bit on this whole issue of
listening and people often ask how do
you listen to stuff that you don't
understand of course you don't listen to
stuff that you don't understand you
progress from beginner material as
quickly as possible into compelling
material so that you're actually
motivated to listen to it and read about
things that are of interest to you so
hopefully that is of interest and thank
you for listening and I look forward to
hearing your questions about listening
and finding content and by the way don't
say don't ask me where do I find content
without telling me what language it is
that you're interested in finding
content for but do try to if you don't
know how to say podcast or audio book or
ebook and on history or music or
whatever use Google Translate come up
with a search term and then see what you
can find okay then thanks for listening
and bye for now
[Music]